so I'm gonna start with a few questions
that I didn't ask the other night which
is um what do we have to do or what do I
have to do to get you Andy Angela make
about five more of these films well
bring your family of seeing eyes out on
Thanksgiving it's the only answer if
this movie does even okay I will I will
in a heartbeat make more of these with
Daniel man we had so much fun making
this the idea of getting together every
few years to make a new Benoit block
mystery that seems like heaven to me um
I have to ask you do you actually in the
back of your brain have an idea or is it
sort of like I can't even let myself
think about that until the movie comes
out but I'm not gonna let myself say
anything until okay I want Kay then when
I count my chickens before they hatch so
we'll see you know how much I loved this
movie but when you were writing it did
you realize were you writing it to be as
funny as it is did you rely or what like
I mean whether does it play bigger than
you actually thought or were you aiming
for this kind of humor I mean I knew I
wanted to be really funny I think it
plays funnier than I thought because of
this cast and because this cast you know
it takes a really good actor to be able
to give the kind of big comic
performance these people are giving and
still keep it grounded to the extent it
has to be grounded for the movie to work
so when I was writing I had no idea
we're gonna have a cast of this caliber
and I think they really elevate the
material in a lot of ways including the
humor 100% yeah what was it like listen
there's a lot of times where it's just
like an actor or two working sometimes
as a few and then there's a few scenes
where it's the entire cast talk a little
bit out when it's the entire cast
working what is the energy like on set
and what is it like to block those
scenes where you have everyone well that
was a big lesson for me for this is what
you got right to the heart of it
blocking for big groups of people which
I'm not very used to and so that was a
big learning curve from me but then you
get everyone on set and Jed they've all
feed off of each other it's like nothing
else when you have a big group and
they're especially the scenes where
they're fighting with each other and
then for me I'm also just figuring out
with the camera how do I cover it in as
few angles as possible because you don't
want to just like get close-ups
everybody and take
three days to shoot that the energy will
dissipate so it's a lot of factors but
mostly it means I get to sit back and
watch all these guys having fun with
each other you know I suppose I've
spoken to deacons and he talks about how
he always shoots with like it's one
camera not no coverage yes just he puts
the camera where it needs to go how do
how do you guys like to shoot and in
terms of are you you know what I mean
yeah do you do a lot of coverage not I
don't do a lot of coverage you know and
it's not to say I shoot everything in
one hour or something but if eclis
storyboards I know exactly what I want
for each of the different angles Steve
and I have kind of learned how to use
two cameras on Star Wars we kind of were
trapped our Heather rounds for the first
time how to make a second camera useful
so we do do that sometimes but more
often than not I'm getting my hero shots
I know what I want
I'd I'd light I love blocking so wide
strain into close-ups as they need to
and yeah I like to be really intentional
with the camera I always like to know
what scene required the most takes and
why oh my god let me think there was
some I'm trying to think what the scene
was with Anna and Chris Evans where she
got the giggles and they you know they
like the giggles on set we're an actor
for some reason just starts giggling and
starts laughing basically during the
takes and it really is like a thing
where it was like eight takes because
she kept cracking up during the scene
it's really it's a thing that actors
know about like it's not even like
something funny is happening it's just
something infectious gets in your brain
and you just started giggling when the
camera rolls when you look at the other
actor it was something in the car I
think that we were shooting with them
and they was just like over and over and
it's just you have to wait for it to
pass it's funny
on that note congratulations sir I hope
that's the massive hits you can make
another appreciate